our subject for this evening living loud
without shouting
what did i say
out of the depths have i cried unto thee
o lord
lord hear my voice
let thy ears be attentive to the voice
of my supplications
if thou lord should mark iniquities
o lord who shall stand
but there is forgiveness with thee
that thou mayest be feared
i wait for the lord
my soul doth wait
and in his word do i hope
my soul waited for the lord more and
there that watch for the morning i say
more than they that watch for the
morning
let israel hope in the lord for with the
lord there is mercy
and with him is plenteous redemption
and he shall redeem israel from all his
iniquities
blood is good
all the time and all the time
good evening everyone
how are you
how was your day
the lord brought you through
well he certainly brought me through did
anyone have a particularly difficult day
today max your hand oh you had a hard
day all right but you are here
so god has been good
you know sometimes well not yet
sometimes god allows difficult times
that he might demonstrate his power
are you following me
if there weren't any hunger there would
be no memory mammoth
if there wasn't severe thirst there
would be no water from the rock if there
wasn't the threat of egyptian recapture
there would not have been the miracle of
the destruction of the entire egyptian
army
god sometimes allows
circumstances in our lives within which
he can demonstrate his power
and so we thank god for bringing you
through welcome to those of you online
wherever you are on this round earth
which some people say is flat
we thank you for your presence among us
and may the lord speak individually to
every one of us in this sacred building
and wherever you are in your homes
online
in your countries
today is tuesday the one
seventh
of uh
december a very serious day in the
history of the united states but i won't
go into that but we thank god for his
sustaining power
is there anyone with us tonight who is
not a seventh adventist race your hand
all right okay good we've seen you
before thank you very much have you been
with us before my sister
in the back
where are you from
chestertown all right chestertown is a
nice place very small but nice good to
have you may the lord bless you sister
karen and make you a light wherever you
go any other visitor with us for the
first time anyone else beside cat oh
what's your name
famous actress
nice to have you we have a celebrity
among us
and we're grateful for your presence god
bless you i really mean that take care
of you protect you from all forms of
armor and danger my brother did you
raise your hand
as being here for the first time yeah
what's your name
isaac carroll
nice to have you brother isaac that's a
powerful by the name
god bless you and may your home be a
place where the presence of god is all
the way felt and where his provision is
always provided somebody say amen for
all our guests
did i miss anyone
did i miss anyone okay who has come
every night so far
i have also come
every night
and i'm grateful for that can you say
amen for the preacher
our subject for this evening living loud
without shouting
what did i say
what was our subject last night
an offer god cannot refuse and tonight
living loud without shouting
before i get into the message of or as
always i ask you to preserve reverence
where you are and i direct this
particularly to our friends online
because you're at home
football game or basketball game but
let's worship god in the beauty of
holiness
when god met moses on the backside of
the mountain in exodus chapter 3 god
said put off thy shoes from off thy feet
for the place where on thou standest is
holy ground that dry
area became holy because of the presence
of god
and so if you're at home you're in your
car wherever you are we are worshiping
the god of heaven and earth and i appeal
to you respectfully preserve reverence
where you are favor number two while i'm
speaking pray for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touch my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth
and as surely as god lives i want to
speak his words i have listened to
preachers on television many times and
i've literally said to god father please
shut that man up
don't kill him father just shut him up
don't kill him don't kill him shut him
up really i have said that when i hear
some of the things that come from the
mouse of some preachers on television so
i simply want to say thus saith the lord
is that okay with you
favor number three
what's that think
isaiah 188 first part of that verb come
now let us do our reason together let's
reason together please heads bowed eyes
closed
god
we come into your presence at your
invitation
spoken to us through jesus christ come
unto me
and in hebrews 4 16 let us come boldly
to the throne of grace
we come there god
we ask you immediately father if we've
displeased you forgive us dear god and
with your forgiveness give us power to
avoid the things that displease you
grant us your spirit a god
that he may use me according to your
will i surrender myself to you a god use
me father as a musician uses an
instrument tell me what to say how to
say when to say it
and may i have the humility of my savior
to listen when the spirit instructs me
a special blessing
god touch their lives very personally
father remind them how much you love
them and you have a home prepared for
them if they will simply obey you
through the power of jesus
that's all those online give them god
bless every country represented by those
listening
move upon the minds of the leaders that
they may always remember in all the
decision making
that the lord god rules in the affairs
of men on the kingdoms of men now dear
god put your healing hand upon anyone
who has spoken 19. grand healing to that
person father not just improving their
god i pray for
healing for those persons and whoever
else has aches and pains be merciful to
them father now their god we commit this
service to your glory speak to us i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
as several of the adventists
we have a message called the three
angels messages
they're not ours they're in the bible
but
we believe they've been committed to us
to give to the world let's go to
revelation 14
we'll read from verse 6.
revelation 14 6 and i feel confident in
saying the only time you'll ever hear a
message on the three angels of
revelation is if you sit in a seventh
day after this church or listen to a
seven-day adventist program on
television that's the only way you will
hear about the three angels of
revelation 14.
i won't go into those messages but i
want to direct your attention to verse 6
of revelation 14.
i will read from the king james version
of the bible
are you there
really if you have my version you want
to say it without looking but let's read
and i saw what
an angel flying were in the midst of
heaven having the everlasting gospel to
preach unto them that dwell on the earth
and to every nation kindred talmud
people say with a loud voice fear god
and give glory to him for the hour of
his judgment is come and worship him
that made heaven and earth and the seas
and the fountains of waters
this angel proclaims the message how
with a loud voice
let's go to revelation 18.
this is a companion message to the three
angels messages it is really uh
intensification
of the third angel's message it is
called the loud cry revelation 80 1-5
and it is particularly directed against
those in what the bible calls babylon
which is false systems of worship and
there is a tremendous call to them come
out of those systems revelation 18
reading from verse one
and after these things i saw an
come down from heaven having one
and the earth was
likely with his glory the earth
not just
chestertown
the earth so john saw this angel
and he cried mightily with what
a loud voice but the king james says are
strong it's the same greek word mega
which we found earlier he cried mightily
with a strong voice and so we have a
strong voice the first angel while the
word loud is not mentioned for the third
angel in revelation 8
it is certainly mentioned in revelation
9 the third angel but we must assume it
also for the second angel and so we have
these loud
messages
why
loud so that everyone can
hear
clearly then these are fighting and
important messages and because they
occur in revelation we have recently
assumed they have to do with the end
time
there's a message for the end time that
must be given loudly the loudness of the
nexus does not guarantee acceptance it
guarantees hearing
so that no one can say what
i can hear
and this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto all nations and then shall the end
come no one will be able to say i never
heard because it will be preached loudly
this concept of loud loud is all through
the book of revelation
let's look at loud again
let us go to acts 14. paul and barnabas
i believe it was are in uh lystra
and there's a man who's been crippled
that's the word the king james uses from
from birth
and in verse 10
we find out something about paul acts 14
reading verse 10. what does that verse
say
acts chapter 14 reading verse 10 do you
have that
verse 10 says what
and said how
with a love voice stand upright
on thy feet and he leaked and walked now
why did paul have to heal this man with
a loud voice why couldn't he have said
stand up right
on thy feet
why a loud voice
okay it might have hurt him all right
let's go to john 14.
not john 14 sorry john 11
the racing of lazarus
we'll read verse 43 of john 11 our
subject living loud without shouting
you have john 11
verse 43
and when he thus had spoken read with me
now
he cried with a loud voice what did he
say how did he say
come on how did he say
loudly i want you to imagine the scene
let's say there's a hillside
and there's a cave at the bottom of the
hillside
the hill is green
but the stone has been rolled away it's
a circular stone they rolled it away
it's to the left there's the dark
opening of the cave there's a dead man
in there there's a crowd all around
jesus stands outside of this opening
it's dark but there's a dead man in
there called lazarus whom jesus loved
and jesus stands outside and shouts
what did he say
say the way jesus said it
the dead man lazarus heard his name and
he came forth bound hand and foot the
bible tells us in verse 44 of john 11
why did jesus have to sh
there's something
about a loud voice that has an impact on
people if you're a policeman or you know
any policeman you know they're trained
to use what kind of voice
a command voice
so when they give you a command get out
of the car you're getting out when he
tells you turn around you turn around
particularly if you're resisting then he
has to use that command voice to get the
reaction that he desires
aloud
what's our subject
living loud without shouting
genesis 1
it's 7 16 i'll release you before 8.
you have genesis 1
nobody answered
let me pray again father in heaven as i
continue
doing my best to represent you father
usually continue to control my faculties
their god in jesus name i pray amen
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth reading from verse one and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters read with me now and
god
that's fine i know you know it and god
said
what did he do
he spoke
how do you think he spoke
exodus 20.
we read the first one
and god speak all these words saying
i am the lord thy god vision brought me
out of the land of egypt out of the
house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
and he lists the commandments all the
way down to verse 17. what kind of what
do you think god used
amen a loud voice
and the bible tells us in hebrews 12 26
that when the commandments were spoken
god's voice shook the earth
hebrews
whose voice then shook the earth now we
know from
1918 that the entire mountain was
shaking
a loud
voice but a loud voice does not always
require
the voice
to have the effect
let us go
to ruth chapter one let's look at a loud
voice no shouting
as we continue living loud without
shouting
ruth chapter 1 we'll read from verse 14
7 20
i move so quickly
that's why jesus told you this what
they'll do is of that they'll do it you
quickly do quickly because time will
pass you by
ruth 1 reading verse 14
and they lifted up their voices and wept
again
and opera kissed her mother-in-law and
was ruth clave unto her
and she said behold thy sister-in-law is
gone back unto her people and unto her
gods return thou after thy sister-in-law
naomi tells ruth join oppa and go back
to what you're accustomed to they were
from moab naomi was going back to uh
where she came from
ten years earlier she was she had left
her homeland because of famine
verse 16
and ruth said
entreat me not to leave me
or to return from following after thee
for wither thou goest
come on read with me i will go
and without lodges
i will launch thy people shall be my
people and thy god my god where thou
diest
i will die and then will i be buried
the lord do so to me and more also if
ought but death pardee and me
read verse 18 for when she
saw come on that she was
steadfastly minded come on
to go with her
she left speaking unto her
now that's a loud
[Music]
she realized
there's nothing i can say to ruth
finish my word
that will change your mind
that's a loud voice without shouting
amen
intrigue me not to leave thee
or to return from following after thee
will thou goest
i will go
and where thou largest i will judge thy
people shall be my people thy god my god
without diet i will die and where will i
be buried
the lord do sultanly and more also
if ought but death
for me
and me
many times the devil bothers us because
we don't speak with a loud voice
to let him know
he has to kill me
i will not do what he says
remember the devil is the most
intelligent being god ever made when he
was lucifer he has not lost his
brilliance
he still hasn't
he knows when he's wasting time
with a particular temptation
so he'll drop that go to something else
when he told jesus turn the stones to
bread and jesus confronted him with thus
saith the lord he didn't try it again
am i talking to myself
are you listening to me
he didn't try it again because he
realized why
it won't work
so he tried something else what happened
it didn't work he tried something else
he got tired and he left
then he comes back but he had to take a
breather
because every time he came jesus hit him
over the head with the word of god that
is a loud voice without shouting
and so ruth said to know me virtually
there's nothing you can say to turn me
from following you
we have friends particularly in high
school or
elementary school or
junior high
they do not hear a loud voice from our
young ones
i don't do that
i don't smoke
i don't treat young ladies that way i
don't do a loud voice without shouting
just by the way they conduct themselves
it has to be a loud voice that let their
friends know you're wasting time with
him
let's look at another loud voice
acts chapter 4
let's read verse 13.
written by luke luke two books two books
ex and luke
acts 413 now when they saw the boldness
of peter and john and perceived that
they were unlearned and ignorant made
their marvel finish that first for me
now and took knowledge of them that they
had been with jesus something about
those men told the sanhedrin they are
followers of jesus
that's a loud voice without
shouting
they took
they had been with jesus
do our friends take knowledge of us that
we're christians or are they guessing
you see a lot of voice eliminates
guesswork
let's look at another example of a loud
voice
let's go to daniel 3.
daniel 3 we read from verse 14.
three boys refused to bow to
nebuchadnezzars
they were brought before the king the
king wants to give them a second chance
because they were very valuable
administrators in his kingdom remember
they passed the test with flying others
in chapter one
and god gave them knowledge and wisdom
but they also work hard
liberalism speak i'm saying to them is
it true or shadrach means
do he not serve my gods
nor worship the golden image which i
have set up
now if he be ready that at what time he
hear the sound of the chronic flute
heart satellite sultry and dulcimer and
all kinds of music he fall down and
worship the image which i have made well
but if you worship not
you shall be cast walk the same hour
into the midst of a burning fiery
furnace and
who is that god that shall deliver you
out of my head and
that's a lovely voice
from the beginning
yeah that's love i will burn you to
death if you do not worship a man
a loud voice spoken softly
verse 16 shadrach meshach and abednego
absolutely said to the king oh
nebuchadnezzar
we are not careful to anthony in this
matter the proper translation is we
don't need to answer you
do we not realize we're not bowing
we don't need to ask you if there is no
our god whom we serve will deliver us
from the burning fiery furnace and he
shall deliver us of thy hand o king but
if not
amen
be it known unto thee okay
that we will not serve thy gods
nor worship the golden image which thou
has set up that's a loud voice without
shouting
we're not bowing
we see the first
we see it
we feel it we're not violent
lovers
no one can listen
we're not bad
god needs people who will speak with a
loved voice without shouting
amen amen
i am
a seventh-day adventist
i don't work on silence
makes no difference to me how many
benefits you daniel before my eyes
for this job
i do not work sunset friday to sunset
saturday why i am a seventh-day
adventist and by denying all those
benefits
expensive college
an apartment in paris one in rome one in
london
a private plane at your disposal i am
not working that's a love for us without
amen
we have a responsibility not to confuse
people
a soft voice has people saying what
yeah
when the voices saw what do people say
what did you say
are you with me
oh come on you're not with me
what did you say
i am a vegetarian
but you know you see the supermarket and
there's
lobsters and
snakes
i can't hear you you said you're
vegetarian
what are you saying
you say you're christian young lady
and when you dress everything is falling
out
are you with me
what are you saying
speak clearly
your boy said
if not
we're ready to die
in defense of the honor of our god we do
not
worship images
living loudly
without shouting
my brothers and sisters
let's go back to revelation 14.
revelation 14.
read verse 6 again
7 30 on the dawn
you have revelation 14
let me pray again father as i continue
to speak to your people
enabling me i pray please in jesus name
i appeal to you amen
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel
to preach unto them that dwell on the
earth and to every nation kindred talmud
people saying with a loud voice say with
me now fear god
and give glory to him for the honor of
his judgment is come and worship him
that made heaven and earth and the sea
and the fountains of waters now keep
this expression in your mind
worship him that midway heaven and earth
and the seas and the fountains of waters
listening to the fourth commandment for
in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea
so this language in revelation 14 7
comes right out of where the fourth
commandment
now this is a message for the end time
if you examine revelation 14 after the
three messages of revelation
7 revelation 8 9-12
1912 or 1913 we have 14 of revelation
14. in other words those messages in
revelation 14
the word of revelation 18 1-5 is an
expansion and intensification of the
third angel's message we call it the
loud crop but essentially messages end
in revelation 14.
one of the messages is
the hour
of his judgment
is coming
and while i can't deal with that now i
can tell you it may frighten you
there is a judgment going on in the
heavenly courts
that has been going on now for quite a
while
and most believers are not even aware
and the bible teaches it
we call it the investigative general or
the scholars call it the pre-advent
judgment christ with the father is right
now determining
whose name will remain in the book of
life or whose name will be removed
everyone loves jesus yes we're served by
faith we're judged by what
works
we're saved by faith
we're judged by works because faith
without works
is there
and so what god is doing is examining
our lives
does the life
match the profession
when that judgment is over
that's when christ comes back
he is not coming back to judge in the
sense of determining who will be saved
or lost because he's coming with a crown
on his head revelation 14 verse 14 and a
signal in his hand meaning he's coming
to nuance reap a harvest and a harvest
is only reap when the fruit is come on
right
now write negatively
or write
positively
negatively against god
for god
that's a message that has to be shouting
the artist's judgment is come
and worship him that made heaven and
earth the seas and the fountains of
water worship the god of creation who
calls upon the world to honor that
creation and honor him by the observance
of the seventh-day sabbath which has
never been changed that has to be spoken
with a loud voice many years ago i was a
little church
outside the trunk
and then we were renting a building and
so on saturday morning i was there to
head deeper and we were pulling up the
banner several services the name was
called
school nine
um
divine service
a gentleman came across the street said
what are you doing say well we're
advertising our services
he said you have service today i said
yes
he said why
today is the sabbath
i never knew that
i never knew that a few years ago oprah
winfrey had a guest on his show and
added this young man
and i think she asked him why do you not
work on saturdays because this young man
worked for the actor called will smith
i hope i have my fax card but he was an
employee of hollywood somewhere and he
told her the assembly is a savage she
said i didn't know that
you know how many millions are in a
position to say the same thing i didn't
know that
this message of revelation
must be spoken how with a loud voice
but the louder voice must be the message
lived out where in our lives
i have a friend
like a sister
said to me why do you always every time
i get on a plane
i'm like this
are you following me i'm like this
because if someone asks me what do you
do
i'm a preacher
well when i say i'm a preacher i want to
no i want to
[Music]
i was going through
customs in south africa
two years ago
lovely country miss it a lot without
pandemic my international traveling has
been interrupted but god knows best
and
there was an immigration officer he
called me
he said preacher
i went to i said why do you call me
preacher he said you look like one.
what kind of voice is that
without shuttle
i left him this is truth god is
listening i left him went to another
office you know the multiple checks with
all the security he said come
why'd you call me then
he said the anointing is all of you
amen
i was leaving
nigeria a few years ago
in my uniform
in my little bag
coming towards this immigration officer
when you saw me come in he took over his
hat
and he bought us he said
he said what do you mean he said but
you're a preacher i said yeah he said
bless me so i blessed him
but he just looked at me
and he concluded now he could have been
wrong are you with me
there's some criminals who dress very
nicely are you following me
he could have been wrong but he said
you're appreciative
i mean i said i pray for him that's what
i mean
i want to speak loudly
without
shout out
and so when i travel i travel a certain
way
i want to look a certain way
not only do i want to say loudly without
shouting a preacher it also makes life
easy when people have to deal with you
i was coming to back home from some trip
overseas and i came to the immigration
officer to check me back in
he looked at me
he said lawyer or preacher which one i
said preacher he said oh the opposite i
said
what am i trying to say
we need to live loudly finish my words
without shouting
as several of the adventists
we keep god's holy day sabbath
we have a health message
we don't eat dead animals
we don't go i'm not saying we put you
out of the church but we preach there's
a better way to eat to take care of this
temple that god wants to inhabit and so
in daniel chapter one daniel hananiah
michelle azariah they spoke with a loud
voice in daniel 18 their purpose in
their hearts that they would not defile
their bodies with the portion of the
king to me but with the wine which they
tried and they would not do it at the
risk of death
they spoke
with a loud voice
without shouting
my brothers and sisters
on the job
as a christian
you ought to be on time reliable
neat
tidy
willing to go the extra mile
by so doing it you speak with a loud
voice without shouting because christian
behavior is not restricted to the walls
of a building
we spend more time outside of the church
than we spend in it and if our only
christian behavior is reserved for two
hours in a church we're not christians
and so on the job we must speak with a
loved ones without shouting
christ is coming back
come on say amen
that is more certain than christmas is
coming in a few weeks
jesus christ
is coming back
he's coming back for a people
who are ready to receive him
a people who through the dwelling power
of his holy spirit are living their
lives how
loudly come on
close the book to let you know i'm
finishing
i want you to make a commitment tonight
by the grace of god
to live your life
loudly
without shouting
wherever you go
it should be our study purpose
to glorify god
by trying to live
a christ-like life through the power of
the spirit of christ without that we
cannot do it we can live a decent life
we cannot live a christ-like life
without the power of christ
how many will say with me father
help me by the indwelling power of your
spirit
to live loudly without shouting can i
see your right
hand stand up with me
let me ask another question
a little more private
who will say with me father as i listen
i realized i have not been living loudly
enough
i've confused people from time to time
can i see your hand
keep it up father in heaven look at the
honest hands that were raised
father we're saying with our raised
hands forgive us
for not living loudly enough their god
and by not living loudly perhaps we may
have caused uncertainty in the minds of
the unsaved friends and relatives who
observe us
dear god
you have chosen us that by our lives
[Music]
without shouting
in jesus precious name let god's people
say amen
[Music]
you